that Jerry at some conferences I saw you
speaking and I was this man was and not
just the content that was coming out of
social media but also his energy and he
has this thing where hello class oh yeah
I'm doing a lot of things but it's but
it's really it's really interesting I'm
doing a lot a lot of things there's 50
other things I could tell you them up to
but it's really interesting and it's
really what we're talking about here in
its most basic form I'm actually only
doing one thing I'm day trading
attention I'm doing one very simple
thing I think the world is in change and
I think that there's over priced and
under priced attention we're spending a
lot of time here I remember from last
year been listening even I was on my
phone for the first 30 minutes here I
think there's a lot of a lot of
conversation here around the content you
know meaning like how do I want to
present myself a lot of things you've
been debating and asking questions about
I think that it's a really interesting
thing to make something happen to make
everything that you want to happen it
takes content and distribution and
there's very few people that are doing a
good job and really understanding both
of them at the same time and more
importantly unlike the world we grew up
in where distribution was so stagnant
and understood the content didn't factor
the distribution into it for example
making a 22 minute sitcom doesn't take
into account television distribution
because it didn't have to whereas making
a video for Instagram or Facebook or
YouTube has to understand how
distribution works to have a chance to
be successful
so artists are struggling with math and
mathematicians are start struggling with
art I'm not sure and that's the truth
because I don't really spend any time on
Auditing who's doing it well or doing it
good or doing it smart
I spend 100% of my time on the end
consumers attention okay
but you also have a personal brand oh
yeah a huge personal brand a personal
brand a lot of people know you as this
person this you know kind of celebrity
CEO and don't even really understand
your businesses but understand you
that's right and the value that you're
bringing to their lives that's right so
tell me about the decision to make
yourself a personal brand and why
YouTube was two months old
I saw it I'm like oh [ __ ] this is gonna
be the next big thing and I started a
wine show in February 2006 i sat a desk
like this and drank four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes and exploded it was you
know Google Flu actual Google Yahoo cuz
it was Yahoo video was big at the time
yahoo and google google had bought
youtube when they flew me out but very
early on I had 20 minutes shows on
YouTube like if you go back to YouTube
in search videos that were made in 2006
nobody was making 20 minute videos like
I was I was just long-winded and talked
a lot and so they dragged out but I I
built a personal brand very early in the
scheme of things because of the YouTube
show and then Twitter came out and
that's when I started getting smart and
started investing in these things I'm
like ooh that's gonna be the next big
thing so I got on Twitter early it was
one of the first 25 people in the world
to have a million followers on Twitter
which was really wild because everybody
else was in from tech TV and you know
diggnation it was very techie Twitter
the first two years I was a wine
retailer in New Jersey what did you
think so I built a brand early what did
you think came more to business was it
just about being famous it was it about
no I thought I was I thought I was I
thought it was gonna do QVC the first
day I did you know Wine Library TV
by the time my stock guy who set up the
camera was set up and we were ready to
film I got scared I said this a friend I
recall this very recently I did
something very early on my career where
it was extremely noble for like pretty
radical reasons that I didn't even need
to or should have even maybe right and
the kid asked me why did I do that and
that my answer was because I'm scared
the date lines gonna roll up on me and
ask me the question intuitively at its
earliest point I understood the Internet
was gonna expose all the shadows of our
society like at a very young age I
figured it out I didn't realize it but
all my actions spoke to it so when Wine
Library TBS first episode started even
though I wanted to sell wine I was like
[ __ ] what if I'm at a party and somebody
gives me a glass of wine and says if
Brian's like hey what do you think of
this wine I'm like oh it's terrible
you're like well you're a piece of [ __ ]
you said it was phenomenal on episode
136 and I was like so scared of that
that basically from the beginning I went
ultra transparent but I thought I was I
was doing it for business I was 32 years
old I was an entrepreneur businessman
there was no fame there was no I was
already you know I was a grown-up like I
wasn't like thinking it wasn't what I
dreamed to do it's nothing that I never
thought that I would like walk the rest
fo like I just did right now and take 9
self like that was never a part of the
equation it was for business I was a
businessman a hundred percent but I
don't think you need a personal brand to
build your business I think you need
self-awareness to build your business
and so one you know even listening to
some of the questions like David Dee's
question here like like when I was
listening to some of the questions the
night I brought this up last year on
this and I I'm gonna say this again I
understand the class you're in but I'm
an unbelievable buyer of betting on your
strengths and punting your weaknesses
and the thought of operators and
entrepreneurs forcing themselves to
create personal brands is laughable
because nine out of ten of them that I
know have no shot or gonna waste way too
much energy or
it's super uncomfortable now that
doesn't mean if you're an introvert you
know it was funny when you talk about
like somebody just standing there you
know I've always thought about
authenticity I'm like if you are
actually just monotone it's like for
example I think entertainment and you
know I have stick fine that works for me
but some of the stuff that I most enjoy
is just depth of knowledge like ah you
know the people that have followed me
around personal brand a lot of them are
not charismatic or pretty or that
interesting they're just such a deep
expert in their field that their podcast
for example is dominating and even their
video of just like them straight the
camera not just apart not all that
charismatic a little bit awkward but
their information
I taught well that's where I'm going I
totally agree it's not about being like
you that you can be shy you can be
awkward you can be and you can lean into
that 100% and then just having context
of like what I'm assuming the ambition
of this room is it's about
self-awareness and and back to my
self-awareness you know as it started
happening I'm like oh yeah I was a good
class clown and oh yeah like I do want
to talk at the dinner table and control
the conversation so like it became
obvious to me like wait a minute there's
something here and then and then when I
made the transition of talking about
business not about wine it really went
to a totally different place because I
you know this is what's great about
documenting everything I was saying
things that nobody agreed with and then
ended up being true you know like like
it just you know I like Instagram is
gonna get bought by Facebook and then it
became true and then I'm gonna CNN for
predicting it and then they're making
fun of me because it was a billion
dollars and I said he stole it and then
if you and if you go read the comments
on YouTube of the clip the first two
years everybody makes fun of me [ __ ]
like pushing propaganda how can you pay
a billion dollars for a company that's
only 500 days old and then the last two
years it's like genius he [ __ ] knew
you know you know and so you know what's
amazing is being historically correct is
the most valuable thing you could do I
think one of the great reasons to build
personal brand is to document you know
imagine watching the documentation of
all the things we put on a pedestal like
imagine if Steve Jobs had a vlog back in
a day like the learning like for me iris
is filming right now what's tough for me
is I'm operating an actual business so
there's a lot of firing and negotiating
and a lot of stuff we don't film I do
film a lot of it just for my grandkids
to watch one day I haven't I haven't I
haven't I haven't done that because I
just I just feel yeah I don't think
that's but I film things that or I'll
ask you know like or like I'll feel from
afar I mean I you know I also am
projecting technology one of the biggest
reasons I document my life is that I
think that my kids are gonna sell the IP
of people being able to be in meetings
with me in the future in a VR
environment so there's a lot of chess
that I'm playing with the like I do a
lot of things I you know what so they're
in so many different sectors and
consulting to retail to entertainment to
I mean so many different sectors talk
about what each platform means which
should help them say okay I need to
spend more time here so let's start with
Facebook okay before we do that just to
frame it up first of all we have to
decide you know what you're doing
meaning or if you know it's I think it's
super you know I always question what
I've even been on social media if I
didn't use it for business purposes like
I don't consume content you were talking
about you know some of the streaming tea
like I couldn't seem very little outside
of like the Knicks and the Jets like my
consumption of actual content because
I'm reading I'm I'm consuming people's
behavior on the Internet that's what I'm
doing and consuming so I think as
individuals Matt and Adam that's great
like I don't think that's weird or
that's fine I think a biz
that's not being on it is ludicrous
right so are you asking me on a personal
brand level or the okay on a personal
brand level Facebook is the single most
important platform still because of
scale just just true general scale
unless what you want to talk about and
what you're about only skews 21 and
under you have to be on Facebook that's
what I was talking about is there's two
ways to play on Facebook you can build a
business page a personal page if you
have any commercial ambitions it should
be a business page they work different
on the algorithm you'll have different
tools so the answer is for business
purposes we're here it's a it's a
business page you should be talking
about whatever the hell you want to be
talking about I know I'm a very big
believer that people overthink this I
think you can go anywhere with it I
think you're gonna look at data and see
what happens some people resonate on a
personal level others don't
again I think this comes down to
self-awareness I also think the type of
content you post is self awareness
there's people in here that can write
their ass off but like freeze when
there's a camera you know I can't put
two sentences together but I could you
know I can do my thing when there's a
camera there's audio there's pictures
there's captioning it you're clever
you're snorting so there's a lot of
variables I think you know one thing
that I want to make sure all of you
understand is that the written word
video and audio have been the way we've
always consumed stuff and it's the way
we will always consume stuff and so I
think one of the things is right now the
medium is so visual that I think a lot
of people here are pressured into
thinking it's about the camera world and
I think there's an incredible upside in
written word and audio I think everybody
at this point understands is a lot
bigger than we thought three or four
years ago
you know so instagrams the next
establishment it is the establishment is
the most contemporary and important
platform in my opinion it's it's already
gotten to the 50 and 60 year old set so
it's pretty much now at scale right
there's an awful lot of attention on it
I think that for most people it's a
requirement as well to me DMing on
instagram is stunningly effective even
to the most powerful people so that's a
little fun fact I think there's access
that's playing out on Instagram yeah I
mean it's an incredibly important
product I I have empathy if you come
from the industry you come from if
somebody says that they're building a
high fashion brand I still think that
cartier is best move is to show a little
humility and a little like not fanciness
so I think anything that acts human
always wins
so for me I'm less Precious about that
but for you and Cartier if that's 90% of
it I understand that but I don't think
it means anything when you talk about my
Instagram looks like a mess I don't
think a lot of people I think we
overthink the way it looks like as a as
a like a net I go on Tyra's account and
we under think about what it looks like
in stream which is how we actually
consume it so I've got a different point
of view than the market on that snapchat
which I don't understand how to use that
snap is still extremely big you know 13
to 28 but the story feature on Instagram
took a lot of momentum out of the system
yep I you know for me I think that uh I
think trading attention I think
snapchats actually one of the most
interesting places to be on right now
because everybody bounced yet there's
still an ungodly amount of tension if
you care about 11 to 30 so maybe you're
you know if you're doing b2b
hardware snap is not gonna matter but
facebook facebook is and i think people
don't understand that Facebook would for
a company like that but again if you're
starting a lifestyle fashion brand and
maybe your audience is Millennials
twenty-five to forty five if you're if
you're a really thoughtful market or
you'll realize that winning thirteen to
twenty two will drive your business so I
think snap matters if your demo if you
care about winning under twenty-five but
I'm not convinced that they make it out
of this they're gonna have to innovate
their product they're gonna have to come
up with something now Snap is very
wisely invested in a are you know they
own bitmoji there's things that are
doing and I think Evans a very uniquely
interesting guy I know them a little bit
I know snap extremely well but I think
to me that is a nice to have versus a
requirement other than again if you're
starting a good e company its
requirement Twitter's the watercooler of
our society you know which has an
important place to be
I think Twitter's more about listening
and reacting than pushing out content
which is why so many people struggle
with Twitter so for example even you
said my Twitter it's a mess at the
engagement slow that makes sense it's a
firehose too much content however if you
personally use Twitter different than
you used everything else and instead of
posting on it it's when you engaged with
people or jumped into conversations or
culture hacked it you would crush if you
guys if you if you would jump into like
when ninja and Drake are on Twitch if
you jump in and like boys leave a seat
for me it would have been huge for you
got it so it's a it's a counterpunching
platform around copy and this is and
this is super important I think you're
getting a sense for me like I'm telling
you right now the world is grossly under
estimating the strategy and nuances of
these platforms like I think you can
tell this is not like hahaha like this
is very deep psychographic mathematical
creative strategy Twitter I think is
remarkably interesting for example Wendy
is growing their business flat out on
the back of snarky and clever Twitter
engagement and guess what Twitter
engagement doesn't cost you $80,000 for
video production doesn't cost you see
where I'm going so there's a lot of
people here who are quite clever and
that might be the platform and that is
actually you know how it's tough to like
well what am I going to post what's
amazing about Twitter is you don't have
to do that you could just follow the
conversations get involved like there's
a meme right now going on based on do
you hear right like the - like I'm all
ready for you yeah right like there's
such a place for that right there's such
a place if you if you're you have to be
creative it's creative writing like this
is where I think improv writers comedy
writers should live on on Twitter
because they have that Sensibility I
exist you have seven people you have
seven eight million fake followers the
way they there would fake because what
they did at one point was they used
Gmail and there was something else buzz
I try to remember they like they've
completely fabricated the top of the
funnel how much you actually had
predicated on how much we use Google for
other things so it made us all feel good
I don't think I generally live my life
this way and haven't thought about it
for four years let alone been there
Lincoln's super interesting because
LinkedIn was a utility for you know the
jobs and thing and it's absolutely
evolved into a Content platform
LinkedIn is an incredibly thoughtful
place for a lot of you it's a place to
do white papers and thoughtful it's an
incredibly interesting b2b place but
it's about producing content it's about
blogging and making videos and posting
on LinkedIn not spamming people and
messaging them till they get a contract
from them and then is there anything on
the horizon this has been
and this is smelling it and that people
need to get on it early because the
earlier you get on you tend to you know
have a bigger following so I think of
social media more as like content per se
right because that's really where it
evolves into I'm completely obsessed
with podcasting I wouldn't call that you
kind of went around the room and said if
you're not doing a podcast I'm
paraphrasing you're an idiot
I'm paraphrasing but it was something
like that and me hearing that not as a
student but hearing that I felt like an
idiot and next year I'm gonna do a
version of that I love it you said that
I was super right about that and like
and I'm happy about it because it's
really helped a lot of my you know all
my contents free my audience watches it
I love the idea of like them benefiting
and so many of my audience because of
that rant that I was going on two years
ago I mean voices get ready like no
question most exciting thing for me and
technology is the voice Platt and
blockchains
an unbelievable technology it's the
Internet itself there's so much to talk
about
AR is gonna be super rad machine
learning and AI super interesting but
for me the reason I'm obsessed with
voice and the apps that are gonna be
built on top of Alexa and Google home
and Apple home pod is that we're about
to be affected for real for real in
about 36 months like you are going to I
would say yeah I'm looking around like
you know you would have never guessed I
bet you all of you looking around just
kind of like gauging ages here it would
have been hard for you to believe how
much texting compared to how much phone
calling you would be doing if I sat here
eight years ago and said I promise you
96 percent of your behavior is gonna be
texting not calling you would have had a
tough time making that leap you would
have said maybe 5050 I'm saying it right
now remember it one day I can't wait for
you to email me you were gonna be blown
away by how much voice interaction
you're gonna do in seven years you're
not gonna type you're not gonna type
which is like crazy right god we're
always look look guys everything goes in
a circle right everything goes in a
circle I didn't think I was gonna type
in my life sitting in high school I'm
gonna be an entrepreneur I'm not gonna
type I'm gonna [ __ ] use tight why
would I type
that my whole life became type right
it's all type it's all like now we're
all deep into type we're gonna go back
to it because what we care about is lack
of friction and speed and it's going to
be faster for you to do something with a
voice device always on everywhere always
than it is to take out your phone and
text your mom maybe like mom I'm gonna
be late and it's gonna be done we're
talking about like so like it's way way
way way way bigger than you think
of course it's always a generational of
course of course and and eventually
we're all gonna understand that privacy
doesn't exist which is gonna be the best
thing for the human race just to on the
record piracy caught that it's shut it's
just going to be I think you can get in
trouble when somebody else has leverage
means if you work for somebody or if you
are being financed by somebody they have
say I don't think you can lose with the
audience I think that's been proven time
and time again
you basically say you're sorry and you
move on it's a remarkably human thing
it's why we're still around our
compassion ability to forgive is
enormous I mean think about what you'd
have to really do to massively I mean
we're where you go I mean you got it
you're really into like the most extreme
territories which is if you're doing
those things if you're murdering
somebody I promise you the tweet is the
last of your concerns so so this place
of like I can [ __ ] this up
you really can't where you can so the
audience the audience the market you
have no danger
you have danger if somebody has leverage
on you you have danger if Rick the VC
who's about to write you a check didn't
like that you said that and now doesn't
and I think the reason I've been able to
live so free is I've never put myself in
a place where somebody has financial
impact I mean Tula is super fired up
a question so I actually I'm sure you
probably know someone it's guys like I
used to watch like these daily vlogs
every day but Casey my staff and this
other guy Jesse that was always with him
and both of that eventually I stopped
doing their vlogging and their social
media presence or severely doubt the
fact because they were talking about
having this mixture of personal and
professional it negatively impacted
their business is negatively impacted
their personal relationships so I want
to kind of get your view on how to be I
don't think I don't think we stopped
that from happening you know we're not
gonna make rules of that like that's
that never works I mean if you look at
Casey's situation he stopped for two
reasons one sake one he got 25 million
dollars from CNN two he you know when
you do something for a long time you get
burnt out
he's also super back you know last month
he started a full studio for it he's
also started a podcast with his wife to
talk about the issues of it so I think
you have to watch behavior I you know I
think we we overthink that we can
regulate stuff what I like about the
Internet is it's exposing us not
changing us like how do you stop you
stop like I don't think it's up to us or
Google or Facebook like I love all this
Facebook talk like people are mad for a
platform exposing who you actually are
so you know my point of view is I don't
think it's a I I don't think it's as
much of a collective conversation as
people think
for example people want to say that
social media has a lot to do with
teenage suicide and bullying what they
don't want to talk about is that
modern-day parenting is so over coddling
we do not put our kids in a position to
feel any detrimental actions in the
first seven years of their life which
then forms a reality that they're so
entitled and unable to deal with any
adversity that so we are not we are
having very basic conversations
some more with the basic conversation
that people are so scared to do anything
to say anything because of the mob
mentality and now there is no trial
before fire so talk about that that the
data sweet but really like the data
doesn't the data doesn't show that so
well well
well let's talk about it you're saying
that people don't want to talk people
are talking more than ever
no I'm saying that people are scared to
be free with their tweeting or their
social because they're scared that
something is going to happen oh but it
but that seemed pretty thats let's say
jess is like that well that's who she
would have been in life again technology
is exposing who we are like there's
millions of people who are not there's
people who are I just don't agree with
you I just I love to know who but I
think you see I think ruining your life
is very different than having turbulence
for two weeks I see it constantly
because there's a moment the what the
woman let's talk well let's talk about
the combination let's talk about the
most extreme case the woman who made a
racist joke about HIV in Africa and was
on a plane and [ __ ] Google made the
search result to her follow her plane
path and when she landed in South Africa
everybody was there she's doing fine no
listen I really want to have this combo
cuz there's a smart crew right let's
have smart conversations ruining life is
just not happening from a tweet I'm just
gonna put it down like if you can show
me the ones like it's just not I go
ahead what
yeah but but the action is what you have
to look at like tweeting like [ __ ] you
or like using the n-word or like things
that we would be super offensive and
reaction to is not ruining lives the
actions of like of like engaging with an
underage woman in sexual behavior like
you have to map to the action not the
tweet of course but but he could have to
write like again I think we're having a
you know I think we're having a really
interesting but he but he could have but
he could have and people have and I
think the more important question is
that what happens next because now the
Anthony Weiner who's 11 know that the
world is watching much more and it may
formulate his behavior and never got him
to place because the world that Anthony
Weiner grew up in and the world that I
grew up in was mainstream media
protected all this bad behavior Matt
Lauer and Harvey Weinstein and Anthony
Weiner's of the world were protected by
the alternative to the Internet called
traditional media protected let's just
really and likes about alternatives so
we demonize this new technology which is
actually doing incredible good for us as
humans we're just in a certain chapter
where we're going through the middle
stage where we're reconciling know I
actually I apologize let's let's let us
three have this for 5 2 more minutes
because it's important you disagree
meaning no I'm gonna
especially in politics but he's the one
that took that action to the group which
which was then the final catalyst of his
downfall
right like there's probably thousands of
other politicians doing what God please
God let's roll the internet doesn't
change it exposes so a hundred thousand
percent but the internet but the
internet like to me the question is like
a tweet that you know isn't like let's
go back to the original seed a tweet or
the form of communication isn't the
culprit there's there's far deeper
things that we've taken this
conversation to write like Michael Vick
going to jail for having dogs fighting
and Ben Roethlisberger raping two women
is a very big difference one's a white
male one's a black male one goes to jail
for fighting dogs one gets away with it
twice that's not Twitter and it makes
companies scared so let's let's not
let's not let's not be ideological let's
then talk about alternatives cool fine
its Twitter then what about what the New
York Times or The Wall Street Journal or
CBS was then like so we rather have
eight three people be in charge of who's
persecuted or not social network on a
platform and because companies
advertisers whatever it is are being led
by the mob they tend to act quick and
swift and fast and it can really ruin
somebody whether it's for two but again
but again the woman on Fox saying
something and everybody reacts on the
internet because the
retweets from Florida could have also
been the New York Times featuring that
you're talking about more scale but I
don't I don't think we're talking about
you know it's a very interesting
conversation obviously we're getting you
know into this which is super fun for me
to me it's just about alternatives and I
don't think somebody's life is ruined by
a tweet but I think the actions if
picked up and hitting the consciousness
of America is and I just look for
example I think Anthony Weiner's
survived anyway like his his political
career in the way that we're
contextualizing it here thank you
he has and by the way we have to
contextualize bouncing back is he gonna
be the Governor of New York
no but where is he like like he's making
well that's where I'm going but that's
the question so I'm trying to answer
yeah but but but let's talk about it in
a different way there it but Taylor
Swift's also used that platform to
create like so you know you this has
gotten very philosophical which by the
way I'll live on I love this [ __ ] but
Taylor Swift is going to have a hit song
in about 24 months cool we'll find out
[Music]
yeah but a focus group of seven is
dangerous yeah I see you as being like
like falling down on social media as
your child that you are defending even
if it is I'm not let me let me let me
let me answer a better way I actually
have zero motion for social media give a
[ __ ] I think I'm being dead serious
percent opposite of what you're saying
cool I'm not I'm defending I'm defending
the human race I'm not defending I'm
being serious
I'm defending how humans react and what
we actually do with each other
and now that we have scale to actually
see it it's something that we're
struggling to completely quantify I mean
it I mean I'm thrilled with the thought
of social media being gone I think we
grossly I think we're starting to
quantify how unbelievably important
Communications is and how it's dictated
everything you know I'm a I'm a child
that was born in the Soviet Union where
my mother is my hero who tells me at one
point in my life that she wrote a book
report that Fidel Castro was the bravest
man in the world and she read it to me
and it just like was you know maybe
because I had that Soviet us kind of
thing going on I grew up in the 80s I
was always hypersensitive just the day
after 9/11 I basically spent three hours
a day on Al Jazeera's website for two
and a half years I'm fascinated by Allah
I'm fascinated by a man walked in threw
a grenade and killed 27 kids in
Washington State and nobody in America
knows about it this happened like I'm
fascinated by communication and so I'm
not defending social just I just think
that we should have more complicated
conversations about it and I think most
people take it very literal and aren't
looking at it at least I don't want to
say it that way I don't think I'm
thinking about it better I just think we
go you know yes without social media the
paparazzi would have put up your picture
yes I'm not saying that it's awful I'm
on it Gary no no I know your honor
you're thinking that I'm saying no no no
no
but I also think it's an angel I think
it's both I think it's both I think the
question where it all started is does a
piece of content ruin your life you know
at its most basic I think it's it's more
complicated than that
I don't think it does and I don't think
I think it's both do you think it's both
and unfortunately I don't have the tools
to debate you because if I had the tools
we would be going so heads ahead but my
silence is because I don't have your
your silence is predicated on the fact
that you can spend all your time between
now and next year's class and you're not
going to come up with the example that
isn't attached to something egregious
and the actions spend the time but if I
was he would go down it would be my jab
jab can somebody do the work for her
yeah
I'm inching on it it's out of your
control so you might be putting it out
there
it hopes a certain reaction and 50% will
react to the other 50% are gonna go
haywire my question is what happens next
cool well I think I what it means is I
think when you went back to the way the
question was phrased and I'm not picking
on it that way it's like can a tweet you
know ruin someone's life I think the
question becomes what happens next you
know I think there's a second part you
know you know when Richard reacted like
you hear it in the headline there's a
moment in time but I'm just curious in
the macro is sure yeah like cool so you
know you said something that was
misinterpreted or interpreted properly
or you said something wrong I mean like
it happens every day like it happens it
happens 40,000 times a day Nipsey Hussle
says something that is inappropriate the
day later it's not I mean I think we are
dramatically more forgiving back to like
back to my I'm debating for people not
you know like the human race not social
media I think we're massively under
estimating our ability to still be
sitting here with all our capabilities
and I think there's a gross
underestimate of the human spirit and
the kindness and the empathy and I think
that's what's playing out what I the
sort of life or death or career rooting
for things what I find is there's often
much more a effect on the nature of what
you're able to discuss as your business
you know I'm thinking of like these
style bloggers they like sort of getting
into reviewing Outlander which is a very
passionate fan base and they said
something like well you know we're not
so into this plotline or something like
that and the fans just kind of left on
them they basically decided you know
we're not going to cover that show
anymore because it's not worth the
effort for us and so they sort of
pivoted to other activities and I can
pick up lots of examples like that where
you might have to tailor the activities
of your
business your brand whatever to
acknowledge that inherent kind of swarm
but that's but that's happened forever
yeah and I think it's just different as
sort of what we're discussing it's
faster and it's shorter but I think the
thing we're spending so much time on the
first 24 and 48 hours of the test and
not talking about the actual impact and
then more importantly what then that
means to human behavior once we go
through a full cycle I think a lot of
what you're seeing now emerging a decade
into this is people being more less
fearful like everyone's like oh we're
talking about less and we're more scared
I think we're more courageous because
people are understanding the
ramifications don't exist to the same
level and how that plays out becomes
interesting from last year you put a lot
of pressure on him okay remember him
sitting in this room and he said that
he's trying to grow this base of people
and he maybe wants to go into politics
remember he's got all these people and
she kind of doesn't know what to do with
them and you said that he needs to
answer as many of them as possible yes
and I saw his face in his face crumble
he just was like what however he took
your advice and he says that he his
social media following has grown
threefold in one year and the the
embrace that he gets from his country he
feels has a lot to do with what you told
him to do which was engaged can you talk
about that to this class and you know
not to rehab our last 15 minutes but I'm
a very big fan of doing the right thing
leads to the right thing and I think
there's a lot of different ways to look
at it I'm blown away by the selfishness
of most people as they try to build a
personal brand it is 100 percent
predicated on them you know they how
many followers do they get how much is
their engagement and so I remember that
moment and you know just put a heart
like just I think bring you know
somebody if you were if you have the
luxury that somebody finds you
interesting enough to consume what you
have to say to not reciprocate that with
an engagement or an acknowledgment or
listening and more importantly for me I
think one of the reasons I've been able
to map a lot of this behavior is that's
all I do I'm my post is actually
secondary it's the what happens next and
my ability to interact and then that
gives me insights you know these the
insights you get from actually reading
every one of your replies and then
engaging with them is extraordinary
there is no data in the world that's
better than being a human that that in
tune with their audience because you're
picking up on so many nuances yeah I
mean I couldn't I couldn't believe it it
more
I agree with you and I think that the
leading indicator there was that
developed
sure
my so yours was a little more Qantas the
the technology is still pretty behind or
advanced depending on the filter you
look through my leading indicator you
know is really just human behavior like
I'll look at how many peopie just little
subtle things start happening just more
anthropology and qualitative stuff like
man a lot of people are really listening
to their you know headset you know just
like listening and then music and then
you start seeing podcast being talked
about more often so you know maybe some
lightweight social listening but you're
always trying to parallel where the
technology is the reason so many people
lose money that come from Stanford is
their tech right they're not they're
human wrong there's an addiction that I
have to it that's stronger than networks
so I get in my car and I can't reach for
it fast enough so is that it could be a
lot of different things I'll tell you
what voice has its passive and so we can
travel and do other things you're not
required to watch and so it fits where
we have evolved into which is we want to
do multiple things and so that you know
we're on the go so the passive nature of
voice is remarkable voice consumption of
content which is why that will grow
obviously the second part and the more
interesting part of voice is the AI and
the devices and just making your life
easier I mean things like you know we we
exchange it for me so I'll get great
I'll give you a great one you were in
New York promoting your book I guarantee
four years from now you would have been
on my podcast because through voice the
one time you might ought maybe I should
reach out to Gary by the time you get to
a phone you're into another thought you
know but I didn't know I saw which was
great no I mean I mean what I mean
fascinated by is everybody here is gonna
book meetings with each other through
voice and it's gonna plug into the
calendar app and decide for us when we
can meet like there's so many
efficiencies that voice is going to be
able to do passing thoughts is where I
was going with that analogy you know so
to me leading indicators are more human
based right so I'll give you a good
example online dating
to me the leading indicator was watching
who and when they started using online
dating not that the technology existed
to connect people together stigma uber
you know like you can't tell a parent 15
years ago that they're gonna want their
fourteen-year-old daughter to take rides
with strange men at night because that's
gonna be safer than them driving
so there's stigmas that we have to get
over robots that one's going to be the
big one
jirô for me zero for me probably a lot
more for you since you're asking it that
way I think again
I'm telling you self-awareness right and
lack of judging yourself there is
absolutely it's cliche no right way it
depends on you know if you're an improv
actor none if you need to read the
script thirty times you know and so like
I it's a very personal mission and to
try to achieve to somebody else it's
just like a hockey player wanting to
become a basketball player like why
you're a great hockey player
you know yep yep empathy empathy for me
how do i empathy like I get a ton of
hate I'm empathetic like if you are
taking the time to spew negativity on me
out of your day you've got you've got
you're coming from a bad place and so to
me it's empathy like I'm so grateful
that that would not be a gear and so I I
don't think I'm not worried about the
judgement of others to the bet you know
and everybody has different levels of
securities and insecurities and
everybody's got their trigger points and
I have mine too
but for me it's a cost of entry and to
be frank for me it's far more empathy
and then for others in here I would just
tell you like to let an anonymous social
media comment
you know take you away from your
ambitions is really not a good idea you
know like we are human beings and it
hurts but what I try to do as fast as
possible there's like it hurts and then
push it back out and to get it away from
me as much as I can and sometimes it's
just going past that person sometimes
it's muting them um it depends on how
nasty the hate is sometimes it's
blocking them and then I get nervous I'm
like wait I blocked them and now they're
gonna see that I blocked him and then
they're super hateful person so is this
gonna make them even more hateful and
show up outside so you know there's just
all of these like kind of levels and
they have to kind of pause especially as
a female you have to pause and go what
chip is if a block is this an ignore or
is this a mute I created show that push
down through Facebook in its video how
do you see I think you do both because
there's no reason not to I'm not sure
but they'll both be there I'm fine with
same obviously I do think there are
slightly different enough where you can
do some contextually different things
but I for example actions better than
words my daily vlog goes on both pretty
much the same the copies a little
different I community manager a little
different but I think they're both gonna
be massive players like like massive
players
the if I deepen that statement there's a
there's the the entertainment value that
they think they need to go into similar
to how much in you prep or not is what I
mean by it being entertaining on video
is a real skill and so just a lot of
people that are especially if you're a
CFO you know math a driven operator it
you know you know there's people that
have both but you can already just you
know see that so many of them don't map
that you know there's the art they're
left the right thing so that what I
struggle when I get sad for my friend
who's building a great SAS business and
she thinks that she needs to start a
youtube show and I'm like like I'm like
you don't have to you're building an
incredible business you can and I'm
thrilled to help you but and you
definitely don't have to be like super
charismatic and like 360 drone video it
gets it gets away from people you know
so that's now a bet betting Our
Strength's police was not telegenic or
autogenic whatever you want to call it
type of voice and now it is
individuals because I can see that the
first way when Brad would put up their
content in general and then you sort of
idiot just to amplify that content so
the second way when you have companies
like triangle that gets to a hundred
million of revenue swimsuits on my feed
employees and others are media being
come down to Philippines and some here's
like where do you see I think I think
that eighty percent of the money that
fortune 500 spends should be on social
media websites I think Facebook is the
grossly most underpriced stock of all
time the same thing they did um print
radio television and outdoor pictures
and videos right like you know I people
Kylie Jenner's cosmetic company did four
hundred eighty seven million dollars in
sales in the last twelve months and
people think it's her social it's not
it's the content they're making on
Facebook and Instagram and running ads
against my friends Facebook ads are so
grossly underpriced and right now
they're running between six and eight
ten dollars CPMs they're gonna be 50 70
80 there's only one stream it's supply
and demand as soon as BMW and fate and
coca-cola figure this out and their
money comes in it's gonna be hard for
our startups to penetrate that feed this
is the time and it's been the time
yep so similar to Tyra and I've been
putting out content since 2006 there's
literally not a single photo of my
family on the internet you know
something my wife and I decided we
didn't want to put a zit my you know
notoriety grew we knew that there would
be ramifications to that we didn't well
it's really funny I mean so many like
that's the move by most business people
they use their kids and their animals to
because they they're they actually think
the currency is how many likes they get
and this is the thing like it's always
to be like what are you doing like cool
you got 10,000 likes but did you sell
any more swimsuits like you know like
what are you trying to accomplish so
Sarah I think I'm you know I feel like
very in control and I also recognize
that people can film and everything of
that nature to me what's in control and
why I love this so much and why I'm
unbelievably optimistic about this I
really AM is you're in control of your
actions you know like
I go the other way and iris will tell
you this and the rest of my team
I'm completely fully on the record
because I'm just them like I'm just not
worried about the collateral damage cuz
I know what my intent is if I make a
mistake that's life and I should own up
to it I don't think they're gonna be the
kind of mistakes that we've referred to
earlier things of that nature so I I
mean I'm probably the most extreme I've
gone to a place where I'm filming every
single moment of my life I have I had a
vine that went super viral four years
ago on the toilet you know and you know
and obviously that's for fun and you're
like kind of like being a little silly
about it but I mean you know this gets
you know again I already went heavy
enough I can get real heavy what I would
say is this you're in control but that's
the beauty of the meritocracy of it it's
not how much you put out it's the value
exchange that you're creating so it's
not how much you're putting out because
to your point you can dilute if you're
unable to maintain if you're able to be
if you have value to bring whether
through entertainment or information it
only exponentially allows you to produce
more
and I think overexposure was something
that was dramatically more relevant when
you had platforms back had so much
awareness a hit TV show in 1983 have 50%
of the country watching it there's
nothing that has that much attention
anymore so it's almost impossible to
overexpose it's it's the long we are not
calibrating the true long tail effect of
the Internet and its impact on
communication and all the sub impacts
that are created from that so much time
on your phone well first of all I think
that's it's the micro because the macro
is I work 18 hours a day that affects
from my relationship to how about like
at home or where I'm with friends I
don't consume anything I'm with them the
problem is that's only 20% of my time
overall so I can exhibit on the weekend
like when I'm really home you might
could see very little and I create even
less so it's really just more like the
consumption the creation with respect to
your job and outside of that correct I
kind of made a quick reference to it
which is like I almost debate if I would
be on it I genuinely curious if I would
have used it had this snap in my life
some you know what's weird about that I
also don't think I would have drank
alcohol if I didn't grow up in the wine
business like I didn't have a single
beer and I got you know so it's been
funny that my life is kind of like that
but because it is my business and my
again I kind of broke it down my
business is people's attention and
people's attacked like I don't consume
anything I don't want YouTube videos I
don't like I just I I will watch a tweet
in its individuality not she posted it
her post thing about a subject matter
and you guys engaging with it it's what
I'm consuming which is why I'm sure you
even could tell like you know it's not
about being right or wrong I think my
points of view are grounded in
she's a mountain practitioner ship and
an awful lot of energy towards trying to
figure it out Bert awfully long period
of time yeah but to me I'll tell you
something else let me let me actually
answer your question now in a dipper way
I think it's great that every single
person sitting at a dinner table looking
at their phones it means that they don't
value that person in that moment so I'll
give you an example if you're always
with their best [ __ ] friend like
always like you spent nine out like in
college you're always together or at
work if you go to a restaurant and
you're both on the phone and who comes
in and sees that in judging technology
you're missing so much in the context of
why that's happening if you're a married
couple and you're on your phones the
whole time on your one dinner date every
Thursday night that's probably a leading
indicator that your marriage is not in a
good place so I again it's not that I
love social media it's that I love
people I think people of course people
will give you the tell I understand so
much about everybody here just on how
they dress that is your biggest
indicator to like I think we I like to
deeply think about the psychology of it
all so to me like people judging
somebody being on a phone is just a very
shallow point of view what's underneath
that is everything
I get it man i really unbelievably don't
think it's a requirement
I think it's leaving something
unattainable for a business opportunity
for sure but okay like like there's a
whole much more interesting debate about
that what do you want right like if you
want to practice that does 3 million a
year you can get through that easily
without social and then if that's what
you wanted then that's what yeah what do
you do right so what I know is you
writing one LinkedIn blog post about
your thought of blockchains
impact on the yen could be the single
piece of content that changes the course
of your career
correct but to that point right to that
point I think I think content is the
gateway drug to opportunity but I don't
think it's I don't think anything is
required pleasure how are you nice to
meet you um I'm big into difference of
like Benjamin public figure back in my
home Wow so a lot of a lot of awareness
in Kenya yeah and surrounding countries
maybe yeah I've only really been focused
on Facebook more recently in the last
year when I started realizing the power
of the brand and what cachet canary I
had been doing really nothing and I had
a little bit of an organic following so
then I started this show which also it's
like me sitting down with people into
being
I think it's suited for podcast they're
having around them but Facebook here's
the great things so for example right
now this is a podcast as well what's
amazing about video is you could strip
the audio yeah like I have a top 100
podcast in the world and I never sit
down to do a podcast it's just ripped
audio out like I'm sure it's probably
gonna be the I'm sure that rant with me
and Tyra is gonna be an episode in 7 to
15 days so you so you should rip the
audio yeah and now you've got a podcast
yeah and that's important don't create
friction for your audience some people
want to listen you know what I mean
no I think I think you bill if you're
filming you're doing a show in your film
you've got a hundred podcast interviews
you strip the audio and upload it you
don't even need to use anchor you can
upload it find that time and then in
terms of Twitter I love the engagement
of it I mean that's that's it's the
easiest gateway into the game you don't
need a designer you don't need a video
person I just engage all you see that
look I think there's you the biggest
rule is you like for example I don't put
myself with photos with famous people I
I don't like it I don't know why I've
spent a lot of ever asked Tyra for self
like I don't like but other people think
and but that doesn't mean I'm right or
wrong it's being right or wrong for
yourself but it's content you got to put
out content and people overthink it and
and overthink it and then you're just
not producing it's going to be the
leverage because this world is bigger
than traditional so it's going like this
so you got to do it and it will get you
there or or it will just become it
you'll realize that you'll be able to
keep all the economics
for you okay really resonate is not just
my head
no correct that's right that's right I
mean like this is you know I'm so I knew
blogging was gonna be big in two
thousand two three four but I didn't do
it cuz I was I was running online
business I didn't have the luxury of
being able to afford a writer and I
can't write like it's just not my thing
and so I had to watch that whole train
go by yeah I mean that's why I think
it's so special about amateur internet
now they're all in play right whether
you want to do a podcast or audio
whether you want to do video whether you
want to write
they all have massive scale and so like
I feel like I mean you could be a
cartoonist you could be an animator like
our ability to communicate yeah I think
that's I don't I don't I do that as what
everybody's going through I get it
and bath bombs my kids
I struggle with growing I'm actually
hurt of all my images are consistent how
many well because because that's just
that's just 1/10 of it all like a growth
strategy around distribution matters
like what hashtags you use who you DM
how you collaborate alright you know is
it fully organic is there's so many
barriers because you know cuz all your
pandering to is one vanity metric that
isn't the indicator to the reality it's
kind of the philosophical question we
had there we're just having too much
surface level combos surface level no
strategy surface level right I would
tell you that the people that are growth
hacking and getting five hundred
thousand followers the wrong way prick
the masses but lose with the real
currency and then lose
the real version of follow for follow is
spending 40 minutes while you're laying
on your bed because you're passionate
about it
hitting hashtags in bath culture and
going in reading or watching or looking
at the photo and then meaningfully
writing two sentences to add to the
conversation on the photo that you just
saw got it it's it's everything you're
hearing for me is like do the right
thing good things happen do the wrong
thing wrong it's actually that black and
white
I want to talk about starting a
following yep
and I think you kind of went into it a
little bit with you yeah it's one of the
things that I'm really interested in is
I'm moving to New York and I'm going to
be an investment bank okay and it's a
space where you don't see a lot of black
women you know services this is like a
huge home run for you yeah that's kind
of the group I want a 20% and I'm
debating do I try to like start my own
hashtag and following or direct nobody
owns a hashtag there's no such thing
because by nature it could be hijacked
once it becomes something there's nobody
that owns it
so don't even think about that ever
again because think about it like what
it whatever clever financial plus-size
african-american people whatever you
come up with yeah if God would forbid
aka I hope it gets going
well then everybody's gonna use it it's
not an ownable it's a utility for
discovery it's not an audible thing so
you would say like for example there's a
hashtag I love F your beauty standards
and a lot of plus-size women follow I'm
aware of it I know all about it and I
wonder should I start putting content
out there and using that hashtag that
that to me is a hell of a lot better as
long as you're not doing it where you
have to be thoughtful right cuz for
example if you go cash tag right now
Gary the wine club which is my wine club
there's like six spammers who are just
putting their propaganda over it so all
my fans who are watching my wine videos
trying to find other people talking
about wine are getting inundated with
[ __ ] if you jump into and ride a hashtag
you probably want to be respectful of
the hashtag yeah so obviously because
you're part of that culture fine but if
then if all your content is very
hardcore finance it kind of defeats it
so you have to be clever and your spec
phul okay does that make sense
I think my second custom was so where
when you're starting to think about this
the way I think of it is probably start
with Instagram like get my face out
there like my out by well well dependent
let me ask you a question are you trying
to take note to that you're an
investment banker that doesn't look the
part where you're just trying to build
overall personal brand equity so I would
tell you I would tell you that you
really have to get serious about
Instagram and get serious about writing
or making videos on Instagram okay
because you're going to make a quicker
more meaningful impact on that platform
in my belief because you're gonna start
with people that are living the game
versus aspiring to the game Instagram
and the psychology and what's going on
there I think you're gonna find a lot of
friction now I would say do both but I
would highly recommend you to give a lot
of thought to LinkedIn and to whether
you write or you audio or your video
yeah communicate that's Instagram and
then writing blog posts and posting them
into my link that yeah to me to me use
link use LinkedIn and Facebook as your
blog because there's built-in
distribution whereas your own blog at
first oh yeah
whereas that was right in the early
2000s I think building a blog comes
secondary now because you can siphon the
distribution and awareness from these
platforms and what's really crazy and I
don't think people realize this these
platforms are rewarding long writing I
will tell you one of the weirdest hacks
that like I stumbled on by accident and
this is why I always do so much cuz this
is how you find it it was one LinkedIn
post I wrote I just was in the mood just
wrote right and it did well I'm like
okay things are saying you know that I
think Instagram is one of the most
interesting places to start a blog where
the photo is 50 percent of the equation
it's the right there's just so much it's
why I start with attention where there's
attention there's opportunity and what
something starts as evolves television
does not look like the television shows
that started as theirs evolution click
you're welcome good luck yeah
by smooching about different messages
different things you talk about like I
like retail and it's been instructor I
want to like write like short stories
good things how do I push them through
the different channels and do I have to
dedicate one channel do I love where
you're going with this it's a really
thoughtful question a couple things
number one every one of you are
fundamentally different when you're in a
different social network psychologically
you are fundamentally different when you
are literally on your phone on LinkedIn
versus when you're in phone and
Instagram you're just so different you
can't even imagine just like you'd be
different in class than going to Vegas
with your girls for the weekend we've
got multiple gears so yes I think
distribution and that's what I alluded
to very quickly distribution and content
are so much more married than they've
ever been so yes I'm very thoughtful
about what I put in LinkedIn versus what
I put I mean my Delta between especially
because who I am and I play that way the
Delta between what I mean I'm putting
things on snapchat about like a little
van and which I'm not gonna put on
LinkedIn right so I'm playing very high
low and to that point as well on the
flip side I actually think a lot of
times the white space is being a little
bit bubbly or funny or light-hearted on
LinkedIn I think breaking the normal
patterns also works so my interview
question is all the cliched [ __ ] that
we're all thinking right now do that 80%
of the time right my business stuff on
LinkedIn you know did it but I do think
20% of the content to throw it off it
also works because you're breaking up
patterns
[Music]
like no no and I think this was the
point I was making it we obviously went
into the outer space with it I don't
think a single piece of content is as
heavy as everybody else does
I don't think if you're branded as a
singer on your Instagram that if you
made a post about your little sister or
liking cheeseburgers or or like what you
thought about yesterday's tornado that's
some like catastrophic event of you
breaking like the theme and and we're
there's so much ego there's a lack of
humility and empathy from us and the way
we're deploying this content we're in
our own [ __ ] you're one post doesn't
mean [ __ ] once you realize that and it
gets real easy right I see a lot of
people kind of like yeah yeah yeah yeah
want to like showcasing what is my
inspiration
what am i I just referenced it to your
point I think there's a lot of places
you can write so I was an early investor
of medium I think EV Williams is
actually the best entrepreneur of this
generation building tools
I love medium I like LinkedIn but I'll
tell you I think Facebook and Instagram
are unbelievable platforms for long-form
I will tell you this no question a great
piece of long-form written word has more
potential to catch fire on Facebook than
anywhere else and then posting it even
if I have like a personal website I
wouldn't I wouldn't I would write it
natively on Facebook in the post uh-huh
because my belief is that the attention
is worth more than utility of owning
that traffic for me it's built brand you
know people are always thinking
transactional let me have it on my
website so they come there and then they
may use me to me that brand equity is
somewhere much more valuable you writing
natively in Facebook versus it being a
link out to your blog has a
tribution capability of a thousand Delta
because it's not native and Facebook is
gonna downgrade that you've got again
that was a very detailed example of
respecting the distribution you have to
know how the distribution works yeah and
and and I'll I'll give it to you basic
as you go through it always make it
about the audience yeah the audience
doesn't want to click your [ __ ] link
to go to your website they just want to
read in [ __ ] Facebook yeah then you
if your audience isn't there then you
shouldn't do anything right I'm with you
you don't have to do everything now the
I referenced it earlier with a snapchat
thing if your audience is not there and
that's what you want your audience to be
there's the answer is you don't need to
be there there's two more thoughtful
points though number one is there an
audience there that can bring awareness
to the audience you're trying to reach
and that's why Facebook's so powerful
right the amount of times I've been able
to reach Millennials by writing articles
to 60 year olds and having them print it
out and give it to their child like
funny [ __ ] like that and then number two
be careful because sometimes your
audience eventually gets there so like
when I was trying to get brands to build
Facebook up in 2007 and eight they're
like this is Mike we're not our
customers not there I'm like yet and the
reason I really what am i big
breakthroughs early on the internet was
I coined something called the the
grandmother rule
I saw early Facebook people that were
graduating from college start to have
children or maybe they had children
early and they were posting photos and I
was like this is it
I remember like yesterday I was like if
they're gonna be posting their photos
here their [ __ ] mother is gonna be on
this in two minutes and that's exactly
what happened and so when you know dove
and Campbell's like our customers not
there it was only thirty six months
later that they were and then they were
behind got it
my building for the building with my
audience's entreprenuers okay my
facebook is my friend no that's your
Facebook personal page you mean
yeah create a business page and start
making content for that audience got it
it's good face book business yeah your
name your name like if you go search me
on Facebook right now you'll see
actually I think that might be my
default photo for one of them there's my
the one I had from the beginning that
like what have you and then there's the
one that I actually use yep - the guys
are mine you - Adam you guys are both
fighting the system yes because I'm not
trying to build a Bristol brand so
you're trying to establish reputation
here's notice where I was about to go
guys this is reputation yeah when
because the word person a lot of times
we get caught up in semantics of words
because this is personal brand it [ __ ]
with us but we're really talking about
his reputation so all of us would want
that for some reason so again like I
told Adam when he was like now I was
like yeah but your one piece on the
block chains of impact on the yen may be
great for your business it's just
putting out the content what I'll tell
you is and this is where a lot of people
get caught Facebook spy reality and
scale is so great I would argue often
it's going to over index your business
business nerdy business content than
what you would do on LinkedIn because
you understand the let's go cliche the
old white dude who [ __ ] golf's and
runs the [ __ ] business that you're
trying to reach is on Facebook like
people don't get it
especially now now that politics is
playing out on Facebook the
establishment is living on Facebook and
so sure he or she may be on her facebook
looking at their college friends that
graduate in 68 but if your piece of
content
shows up there and they read it your
point of view on the vehicle chemical
engineer like people don't get it it's
scale good quick back stories I was in
public service mr. California so I'm in
business school and trying to do
something of like startups really
interested in social mission driven rub
it love it so my initial thought was
trying to start a podcast of summer with
people who are kind of like cross-sector
because I'm trying to figure out how do
I create some type of reputation like
being a business person yeah it's really
hard to shake five years oh does you oh
yeah I'm like you're terrible yeah I'm
kidding but yes I think that's right
so I have I think you can have two
guests one from each sector and crush I
love the two guests podcast format
because then you're able to siphon
equity from both angles now you'll have
to be good enough like it takes skill to
be a host second manage two people at
once this is where people yeah at the
same time but by the way maybe you're
great at it but like like I think people
take a lot of things for granted you
know like
think of other ways to consume if you
like distill big points on Facebook like
what I would film your podcast and then
chopped up pieces of highlights and
distribute throughout different places
based on what happened let me let me
make a point that I think all of you are
gonna get and this will really tie a lot
of this into a nice bow you have to
think of yourself as a media company not
as an advertiser yeah if you actually
say wait a minute
I'm actually CNN or The Wall Street
Journal or ESPN or or vogue not I want
to be an advertiser in vogue it changes
the way you think about things I only
think about bringing value to the
audience not extracting value from the
audience
advertising extracted value the content
was giving value that was the exchange
of media we as humans and businesses
need to use these distribution platforms
to be the content not the advertiser and
that's where people get tripped up
because you're thinking about it from
the filter of like what's in it for me
like I'm gonna I want to write a book
about this or have people in the we're
gonna let move up get promoted or
whatever it may be or you know make an
impact like have the leverage raise
capital off of my equity whatever you're
always thinking about what's in it for
you
for me I'm only thinking about what's in
it for you because I know the collective
scale of attention by has the collateral
damage of that much attention is
unlimited opportunity for me
third party yep
so self-promotion is I of the beholder
is itself promoting that I would view
her posting it herself and saying she's
teaching at Stanford I think what she
was doing was extracting equity
she was extracting equity from Wall
Street Journal because she comes from a
modeling background and so business
elevates she's transitioning and wants
to be more respected that equity
mattered yeah got it
what's that it's because it changes the
dynamics of how she sees it changes the
conversation
it's in her vested interest she's not
notice how she's not using vogue or
People magazine because she's already
won that game she hasn't won this game
that she uses it yeah it's value
exchange it's not self-promotion that
wasn't self promoting no no no I'm no no
no I think it's no but I'm not being
critical either I'm just high-energy
think about how she put she positioned
it that way but that's not what it was
not in my point of view not the readers
of The Wall Street Journal my friend
know her she got something out of it
with her audience she was able to change
the perception to her audience on
Instagram that follows her for being a
model got it correct she that was a
value exchange for her right
it's why you see a lot of high-low
happening in culture now 21 Savage
having a meeting with Jeff Bezos is a
value exchange for both why is Robert
[ __ ] Kraft
hanging out with Meek Mill it's a value
exchange for Meek Mill he goes in the
hood and in culture and get to say ah
mogul life for Robert Kraft he gets to
say that he's on he gets it he's got
flavor
he's contemporary he's young value
exchange that's what's happening
and that's why if taking it a step back
the reason I've so over-index said is
because my value exchanges I figured out
a way to bring so much value to people
without asking for anything in return
because I'm monetizing in other areas
not trying to get you guys into my
$3,000 a month master class it's why
it's why this is gonna be one of the
only five colleges left pretty soon
you're so you personally off of two
conversations have to think about no no
it's amazing this is why I'm here won't
be like you have to have a totally
different conversation with yourself
which is you are valuing other people's
opinions too much you know and and this
is back to both of you have talked you
talked about the dynamics of women
versus men and stuff emotion you brought
up obviously being an african-american
woman listen to me this is the most
exciting most fashionable thing oh great
I brought it up my mother is my hero
right like like I went to a 94 percent
african-american college of low income
cuz I went to Mount Ida College to just
went out of business
like I've lived a life that put me far
more into places that weren't like I
look like you know I grew up in Edison
New Jersey where all my best friends
were Indian immigrants like I've lived a
very great life to give me a perspective
this internet thing is the [ __ ] game
it doesn't care you have to understand
how powerful this is watching all my
most progressive liberal friends which
I'm an absolute social liberal person be
mad at technology when it is the unlock
to the thing that they've always want
they don't I mean I'm like my friends
we've had it one way for 90 years and
you're not happy with the way it is
don't you understand this is the thing
so so you have you're so caught up on
this self-promotion because there's a
judgement and thinking there's people
think in fancy respectful finance Wall
Street poly fancy [ __ ] places that
self promotions and negative it's just
not let's start with that and what
people are doing in that world is their
disguise
let me tell you what's disgusting what's
disgusting is high-net-worth individuals
going on boards of nonprofits to network
with the other people on the board I'm
telling you I'm telling you I can't put
the establishment on a pedestal they've
lost the leverage and more importantly
they've went about it the wrong way and
once you make that chasm switch and by
the way I don't take that lightly that's
it you know especially when you've been
playing one way it's very hard to unwind
that but whether I'm whether I'm right
or wrong just look at what's happening
in our society if you think that 50
years ago 30 years ago 20 years ago
Matt Lauer is getting fired and Donald
Trump wins an election you're out of
your [ __ ] mind it's over and so I
recommend it and especially since you're
so [ __ ] young stop pandering to an
establishment that was flawed and has
lost its leverage yeah it's it's way
heavier than you think brother I'm
telling you yeah and here's the best
part right here's the best part for me
I'm gonna be right not because I'm smart
because I'm living so deep in the vortex
I'm just watching it's already happened
this is already happened this happened
this is not like it's coming this is
like if you look at every single thing
that's happening you think the [ __ ]
four old white guys that owned all of
media in America we're gonna let me to
happen 20 years ago what do you think is
happening like like when I wouldn't when
my women entrepreneurs' ago on the back
of knowing that they weren't getting
funded properly it was like a business
thing it's not like because I'm the most
noble man it was just like stupid like
for me it's like I don't care who you
are like this business that's the last
thing you should be thinking about like
so a lot of my girlfriends are like
Carrie but cool and they you know
they'll be in my vortex they believe in
a lot of stuff of really [ __ ] man but
like but they're like yeah but guess
what cool Gary but I still can't get
funding from [ __ ] VCS I'm like so
don't take money from these scenes
they're bad deals anyway my friends this
whole [ __ ] thing we're in right now
it's had a great run and it's really
cool and I'm super happy for it but it's
in deep [ __ ]
it's in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] what he should
well yeah so my Weibo and my Facebook
interpretation and my WeChat is on fire
my Facebook translation to Mandarin is
my most viral thing that's going on
right now yeah like I am like and Weibo
is like Weibo is my fastest growing
social network like I'm completely
obsessed with obviously mainly on China
back to like how this how a lot of
things I think are gonna play out you
could do it now you can do it in content
it's all content content is the gateway
drug to everything of course because you
have to reverse-engineer the audience so
I'll tell you the best thing if you're
bilingual the greatest thing you can do
is mix the content between English and
your native tongue in one post to others
it's like Spanglish is the most viral
content on Facebook you know why because
it's authentic it's how you actually
talk like I speak I'll start a sentence
with my mom and Russian and finish it in
English it's how it is yeah and that
keeps going back to so you can start
that now that's the British
all right thanks guys
[Music]